مرحبًا ، أنا دكتور سانجاي جوبتا ، مضيف
بودكاست Chasing Life على شبكة CNN
وفقًا لهذه
الدراسة الحديثة المثيرة للاهتمام حقًا من فنلندا ، إن الذهاب
في نزهة في الغابة أو حتى
حديقة الحي الخاص بك من ثلاث إلى أربع مرات في
الأسبوع يمكن أن يقلل من الحاجة إلى
الأدوية لأشياء مثل القلق
والاكتئاب وضغط الدم المرتفع حتى
الأرق الذي بدأ بالفعل في الانتشار في
كندا. أنه
في
العالم المثالي ، يجب أن يكون كل شخص قادرًا على رؤية
ثلاث أشجار من نافذتهم ، يجب أن
تكون هناك تغطية شجرية بنسبة 30 في المائة على الأقل
في كل حي ، ويجب
أن يعيش الجميع على مسافة لا تزيد عن 300
متر أو أقل من ألف قدم بعيدًا
عن الحديقة ،
لذا اذهب الآن في نزهة في
أوامر طبيب الطبيعة ،
يمكنك سماع المزيد حول كيفية تحسين
صحتك وحياة تشيس أينما
تحصل على البودكاست الخاص بك.